النجمه المغربي اشرف حكيمي لاعب فريق سان
جيرمان من ابرز الشخصيات التي تناولتها
الاخبار في العالم الساعات الماضيه وامثل
فيفا اختارته ضمن التشكيل الافضل لعام
2022 لكن الليله اللي المفروض تكون من
اسعد ليالي تحولت لكابوس عليه وعلى محبينه
اللي انصدموا فجاه بانباء اتهام فتاه لوب
الاغتصاب صحيفه لو باريزيان الفرنسيه كانت
اول من كشف الموضوع واللي بعدين اكدته
مصادر مقربه من التحقيقات وقالت انه فتاه
عمرها 24 سنه توجهت لمركز شرطه وقدمت بلاغ
بانه حكيمي اغتصبها في منزله وقالت الفتاه
للشرطه انه هي مو شكوى ضده لكن هي بس تريد
ان تقدم بلاغ باغتصابها لكن رغم كده ضابط
الشرطه او قضائيه اللي تكلمت معاه تواصل
فورا مع النيابه العامه والنيابه العامه
ورغم عدم تقديم الفتاه شكوى لكنه وضع يده
على القضيه نظرا لخطوره الواقعه ولشهره
المتهم
وتم تحويل القضيه الى محكمه مونتير وهي
محكمه قريب او قرب فارس وتتبع لها المنطقه
اللي وقعت فيها الحادثه المحققين للان ما
استمعوا لاقوال الفتاه بالمناسبه لكن
تقرير نقل روايتها بانها تكلمت مع حكيمي
على انستغرام يوم 16 يناير وفي 25 فبراير
ليلا راحت لعنده على بيته في منطقه فاخره
قرب باريس بسياره اوبر حكيمي اللي طلبها
وهناك الامور خرجت عن السيطره وقبلها غصبا
عنها وخلع عنها ملابسها رغم اعتراضها
واغتصبها ولكنها قدرت في الاخر ان تزيحوا
عنها وضربته برجلها وبعثت رساله لصديقتها
اللي جات واخذتها وفي عطله نهايه الاسبوع
راحت لمركز الشرطه وتقدمت بالبلاغ
[موسيقى]